I haven't read the gay agenda I keep
hearing rumors and I think no I don't
wanna no
it sounds bad
sounds like I might be in Slytherin
wait a second I'm sorry I I don't mean
to get into conspiracy theories but I I
simply don't believe that the audience
is laughing that hard at that joke I
don't there is no way because it's a
it's a Harry Potter reference right no
you've made a mistake this is how in
touch I am with the Youth of today
there's no way that a Harry Potter
reference could cause someone to break
into uncontrollable fits of laughter I
don't I don't believe it the physical
reaction doesn't make sense it would be
like if someone responded with orgasmic
Delight after taking a bite out of a out
of like a graham cracker that there's no
way that a graham cracker could elicit
that sort of response unless you were
starving in the desert for two weeks and
then you had a graham cracker then maybe
it would have that kind of reaction so
were these people were they locked in a
dungeon and not allowed to laugh on pain
of torture for two years